hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live kein Thema wurde hitziger
besprochen in den letzten Wochen keine
Entscheidung so oft gefordert
Kampfpanzer für die Ukraine nun gibt es
Medienberichte Deutschland und die USA
wollen doch Kampfpanzer liefern bei uns
für euch ganz aktuell die Analyse ihr
könnt Fragen stellen Kommentare
schreiben im Stream oder per Mail zu der
Frage kommt das Go für die Kampfpanzer
und wir können sprechen mit unseren
Korrespondenten in Washington und in
Berlin bei uns sind Thomas Reichert und
MRT Wissen schönen guten Abend Thomas
was ist dran an den Berichten über
mögliche Lieferungen jetzt doch von
Deutschland in die Ukraine in Sachen
Kampfpanzer Leopard also die Hinweise
für dichten sich mehrere Medienberichten
heute Abend in Berlin das eine
Entscheidung der gefallen ist dass
Deutschland Leopard Kampfpanzer liefern
würde die redest von einer Kompanie und
den sogenannten zwei A6 Leopard 2
Panzern die da geliefert werden sollen
das sind hinter die Anfang der 2000er
Jahre produziert wurden im Wesentlichen
also relativ moderne und kampfstarke
Panzer sie sollen aus Beständen der
Bundeswehr geliefert werden auch das ist
soweit schon mal berichtet worden
ausschlaggebend war ganz offensichtlich
dass es in den USA Bewegung gab und
damit der entscheidende Vorbehalt von
Bundeskanzler Scholz zur Lieferung von
Kampfpanzer nämlich die USA dann der
eigenen Seite zu haben dass der dann
weggefallen ist du sprichst es an die
USA an der Seite die USA hatten bislang
betont Lieferung von ihren abriens
Abrams Kampfpanzern sei nicht sinnvoll
die müssten über den Atlantik
transportiert werden Instandhaltung sei
sehr aufwendig und sie verbrauchten zu
viel
Treibstoffen kann uns jetzt sicher sagen
ob sich daran jetzt plötzlich etwas
geändert hat was ist dran Niefern die
USA jetzt doch ey brems Kampfpanzer
also sieht alles danach aus auch hier
gibt es übereinstimmende Medienberichte
unter Berufung direkt aus der
amerikanischen Regierung und ich glaube
man kann sehr klar und eindeutig sagen
dass die USA bereit sind Abrams Panzer
zu liefern wie viele das sein werden wir
wissen wir noch nicht Wir haben hier
gerade ein Pentagon Briefing gehabt wo
ähm general Patrick Rider der Sprecher
des Verteidigungsministeriums immer und
immer wieder danach gefragt wurde auch
ob er vielleicht eine Bestätigung hat zu
den Leopard 2 aus Deutschland er hat
immer wieder verwiesen darauf dass er
jetzt nichts bekannt zu geben habe heute
aber wir hören das mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit eben am morgigen
Mittwoch tatsächlich diese
Bekanntmachung
passieren wird dass man in den letzten
Tagen miteinander beraten hat und das
ist eine gemeinsame Vereinbarung ist
Deutschland USA und mehrere andere
Staaten an den letzten Details wird noch
gefeit der amerikanische Präsident wird
mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit heute das
Ganze noch einmal abnicken und dann wird
man morgen diese
Bekanntmachung wirklich herausgeben aber
es gibt hier schon Stimmen nach wie vor
im Pentagon und auch in Kreisen von
Militärexperten ehemalige generelle die
Clowns deutlich sagen dumme Idee den
Abrams zu liefern weil es eben schwierig
ist aber alle sagen eben auch wenn es
dafür notwendig ist damit Deutschland
die Leopard 2 liefert und die Freigabe
erteilt dann die von die Amerikaner halt
eben ein paar Abrams Panzer in die
Ukraine und Thomas ist das jetzt auch so
zu verstehen dass das vielleicht eben
auch eine Entscheidung Deutschlands dann
jetzt beeinflusst dass also die USA sich
jetzt zu einer Entscheidung
durchgerungen haben oder diese
Entscheidung jetzt festgesetzt haben ist
das der Grund für eine mögliche Änderung
in der deutschen Haltung ganz sicher ist
es hat euch heute mal wieder auch
deutlich gemacht dass er sozusagen die
drei entscheidenden Maßgaben für ihn
sind dass es in Waffenlieferungen eben
Bündnis gemeinsam gemacht werden dass
der sich nicht ausweitet und die NATO
keine Kriegspartei wird zu der erste
Punkt ist der entscheidende bei der
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern er hat das
sehr deutlich gemacht überliefert es
auch ein sehr eindringlicher Austausch
von Scholz mit Abgeordneten aus den USA
in der wo es vor einigen Tagen also das
war klar und das hat die Bundesregierung
auch relativ deutlich gemacht ohne von
einem jungteam zu sprechen also
sozusagen eine kausalen Verbindung
zwischen Amerika liefert und dann tun
dass das weders aber natürlich war das
der entscheidende Schritt die Nachricht
aus Washington das zumindest ein paar
Abrams geliefert werden und damit die
USA mit dem Boot sitzen das hat einiges
hier in Bewegung gebracht klar war auch
dass der Druck z.B auch aus Polen in den
letzten Tagen erheblich geworden ist und
es aus Sicht der Bundesregierung so
haben wir es ähm aus Regierung Kreisen
noch gestern gehört dass es da auch
keine Trennung gab sozusagen wenn dir
die Bundesregierung die Lieferung von
Leopard 2 Panzern aus Polen in die
Ukraine freige dann können wir nicht
schlechterding selbst sagen wir halten
uns dann aber zurück und das würde dann
auch bedeuten dass wir selbst liefern es
scheint so aus meiner Sicht dass das nun
beides abgeräumt wird in gewisser Weise
durch die Entscheidung in in Washington
und was immer gerade sagte eine
gemeinsame Präsentation morgen das
scheint mir auch tatsächlich der Fall zu
sein wenn ich auf den Terminplan für
morgen gucke um 13 Uhr ist eine
regierungsbefragung im Bundestag
eingesetzt da wird zuerst Kanzler Scholz
Fragen beantworten müssen die Bundeswehr
ist eine Parlamentsarmee das wäre aus
meiner Sicht ein naheliegender Termin
für Scholz sich selbst und damit auch
die Frage panzerlieferung zu klären
die Zahl der Zeitunterschied mit
eingerechnet wäre das vielleicht ein
gemeinsamer Aufschlag aus Washington und
Berlin dann morgen gegen 13 Uhr
deutscher Zeit zwei wichtige
Entscheidungen die also morgen anstehen
könnten jetzt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
sind das jetzt Medienberichte über die
wir jetzt gerade gesprochen haben was
ganz faktisch heute passiert ist und was
auch eine ja eine Debatte eine Vorsicht
nach sich zog über die wir jetzt noch
kurz sprechen müssen die Regierung muss
nämlich nicht nur entscheiden die
Bundesregierung ob sie eben selbst
Leopard Panzer liefern möchte sondern
eben auch ob sie anderen Drittstaaten
genehmigt die Leopard Panzer aus
deutscher Produktion besitzen und heute
das ist das was wir gesichert wissen ist
eben so eine Anfrage von Polen
eingegangen Polen hat einen sogenannten
ausfuhrantrag bei der Bundesregierung
vorgelegt Thomas du hast uns das ganze
das was wir bislang eigentlich heute
über den Tag praktisch Wissen
zusammengefasten einen Bericht wir
schauen zusammen rein
die brisante Anfrage aus Polen landet
heute hier Scharnhorststraße Berlin das
Wirtschaftsministerium lange angekündigt
bittet Warschau nun um Erlaubnis in
Deutschland hergestellte Leopard 2
Panzer an die Ukraine zu liefern und
schickte Anfrage noch ein paar Mahnungen
hinterher
ich hoffe dass die Antwort aus
Deutschland dieses mal schnell kommt
denn die deutschen zögern weichen aus
und verhalten sich auf eine Art und
Weise die schwer zu verstehen ist
in Berlin heißt es der Antrag werde mit
der gebotenen Dringlichkeit geprüft bis
dahin muss Verteidigungsminister
historius tun was er seit Tagen tut er
muss vertrösten die Öffentlichkeit und
auch den Nato-Generalsekretär die Frage
nach den Leopard Panzern es gibt noch
keinen neuen stand ich habe immer gesagt
ich rechne damit das in Kürze eine
Entscheidung fällt und davon gehe ich
nach wie vor aus Stoltenberg die
Deutschen für ihre Hilfen und drängt zu
mir freundlich doch unverblümt
entscheidenden Moment des Krieges müssen
wir der Ukraine schwerere und modernere
Systeme zur Verfügung stellen und wir
müssen es schneller tun
der Druck auf Deutschland ist enorm und
vieles deutet darauf hin dass eine
Entscheidung unmittelbar bevorsteht
treffen müsste sie am Ende Kanzler
Scholz
deswegen erwarten wir jetzt vom
Bundeskanzler das schnell diese Signale
in Richtung Polen gesendet werden dass
diese Lieferung der Panzer aus Polen
heraus an die Ukraine möglich ist AFD
und Linke sind gegen Panzerlieferungen
sie fürchten eine Ausweitung des Krieges
tierischen Viktor Ukraine zu pochen ist
unverantwortlich den Fakt ist Russland
ist als Atom macht militärisch nicht
besiegbar eben auch nicht mit modernen
Kampfpanzern morgen wird Scholz im
Bundestag Rede und Antwort stehen gut
möglich dass es dann schon mehr Klarheit
gibt
normalerweise wäre so eine Abstimmung
zwischen zwei Bündnispartnern zwei
Ländern hier so nah beieinander nicht so
eine große Sache normalerweise würden
die wahrscheinlich vertraulich
miteinander sprechen dort hatten Polen
aber es sind keine normalen Zeiten wir
haben eben gerade in deinem Beitrag
gehört Thomas was das Ganze natürlich
auch für einen Vorlauf hatte und wie
uneins das wirkt wie wenig abgestimmt
jetzt aktuell gerade in Europa in der
panzerfrage Deutschland der ewig als der
Zauberer wirkt ist das jetzt ein
Unterschied vielleicht auch zu dieser
möglichen gemeinsamen Entscheidung mit
den USA was ist da passiert in den
letzten Tagen mit Polen und mit
natürlich anderen Ländern auch in der EU
wieso wird Deutschland da immer wieder
Zögerer Zauberer die anderen preschen
vor das ist nicht so besonders
abgestimmt gewesen teilweise oder in der
Tat es war wirklich zumindest überhaupt
nicht abgestimmt und Deutschland das
wirklich viel geliefert hat seit
Russland die Ukraine überfallen hat
steht da immer da als jemand der
tatsächlich zögert und zaudert und
Entscheidungen dann trifft wenn alle
anderen schon sie quasi vollzogen haben
oder jedenfalls der Druck so groß ist
dass man glaubt man kann nicht anders es
war bei allen Sachen die bisher
geliefert wurden so das war bei der
panzerhaube zu so das waren zuletzt bei
den Marder Schützenpanzern so die eine
lange lange Geschichte des Drucks und
des Trainings hatten bis dann endlich
nun die Entscheidung viel und die
geliefert wurden besonders eklatant war
nun der Druck tatsächlich bei den
Kampfpanzern weil es natürlich noch mal
eine besondere qualitative qualitative
Schritt ist
Leopard 2 Panzer in den Kampf gegen
Russland zu schicken das ist normal
etwas was wahrscheinlich vom Monat noch
völlig und denkbar gewesen wäre
die Polen haben natürlich darf eine
weiße Druck gemacht die in Berlin nicht
besonders gut ankamen selbst bei jenen
die für kampfpanzerlieferungen waren da
spielte natürlich aus Berliner Sicht
auch der polnische Wahlkampf eine Rolle
aber es war ja eben nicht nur Polen wir
hatten gestern einen EU
Außenministerrat in Brüssel wo die
baltischen Staaten noch einmal
verzweifelt und drängen ähm Deutschland
aufgefordert haben seine Führungsrolle
in der EU wirklich wahrzunehmen und in
Berlin war die panzerfrage eine schwere
schwere Belastung für die Ampelkoalition
wir erinnern uns am Wochenende da der
Streit zwischen
SPD-Fraktion Schiff mit nicht und der
FDP verteidigungspolitikerin stark
Zimmermann das hat weite Kreise in der
Ampel gezogen und es war höchste Zeit
auch für die Ampel selbst dass diese
Frage nun endlich geklärt ist
während wir hier gerade live sprechen
findet auch das Pentagon breathing statt
MRT für uns die ganze Zeit live zu wir
hören jetzt auch gemeinsam mal in einen
Ton rein sprechen gleich mit dir darüber
immer
in Germany aus productive communications
with his German when he is in Germany
that
you aber den
terminktes System
das klingt schon ganz anders als das was
wir da aus Polen gehört haben Elmar das
was wir gerade eben aus dem Pentagon
breathing gehört haben auch über die
Gespräche zwischen dem
Verteidigungsminister aus den USA
zwischen dem neuen deutschen
Verteidigungsminister hat sich da jetzt
auch etwas geändert durch dieses Treffen
was eben zuletzt letzte Woche stattfand
wurden da wahrscheinlich diese
Abstimmungen getroffen was denkst du
also ich glaube man hat vereinbart
letzte Woche dass man reden will und das
hat man übers Wochenende getan und das
Ergebnis sehen wir eben jetzt das ist zu
einer Vereinbarung wohl kommen wird die
morgen bekannt gegeben wird generell
Rider wurde vorhin wirklich ARGE
zwiebelt mit vielen Fragen genau in
diese Richtung und er musste
zurückhaltend sein weil es ist das
offiziell wenn es offiziell ist also
wenn das tatsächlich vom weißen Haus
wahrscheinlich bekannt gegeben wird
beginnt jetzt auch gerade das Briefing
im Weißen Haus aber wir erwarten jetzt
nicht dass da die bekannt machen jetzt
schon kommen sondern eher Morgen und das
hat auch ein Stück weit damit zu tun es
gibt hier unterschiedliche Ansichten im
Pentagon ist man tatsächlich der Meinung
und bleibt dabei keine großartige Idee
die Abrams zu liefern weil sie eben
aufwendig sind und weil die Modelle die
die Amerikaner zu bieten hätten
tatsächlich eben nicht einfach mal auf
Diesel umgestellt werden können sondern
tatsächlich mit Kerosin einem Gemisch
jedenfalls betrieben werden weil die
Wartung die nachschubkette die
Ausbildung alles viel komplizierter ist
der Leopard 2 ist nicht mehr greifen
schneller wendiger feuerkräftiger und
ähnliches und deswegen für die Ukraine
besser zu gebrauchen das hat General
Rider vorhin auch noch mal ganz klar
gesagt dass die Amerikaner eigentlich
nur das liefern wollen was jetzt gerade
in dieser Situation möglichst schnell
hilft und das sieht man im
staty-partment und die Weißen Haus ein
bisschen anders als im Pentagon da sagt
man um Himmels willen wenn es denn
notwendig ist dass wir ein paar Abrams
liefern damit der Leo 2 auch geliefert
wird dann tun wir das und genau das wird
jetzt passieren und der Senator der
republikanischen Parteien in the Graham
hat das vorher noch mal in einer
Pressekonferenz sehr klar auf den Punkt
gebracht um was es hier geht man steht
letztlich vor der Frage ob man zulässt
das Russland in dieser
Frühjahrsoffensive die kommen wird so
sicher wie das Armen in der Kirche in
dieser Frühjahrsoffensive gewinnt also
die UK keine verliert und vor diesem
Hintergrund hat er auch noch mal klar
gesagt es müssen dann eben auch Abrams
Panzer geliefert werden und das ist der
Moment sagt er in dem Deutschland
glänzen kann als Kraft für das Gute und
hier in Washington rechnen alle damit
dass das eben am morgigen Mittwoch der
Fall sein wird
Einschätzung von unseren Korrespondenten
MRT Wissen in Washington Thomas Reichert
in Berlin morgen also eventuell der
große Tag der Verkündung ihr werdet das
für uns beobachten vielen Dank und
wahrscheinlich bis morgen
der Kampfpanzer Leopard laut vieler
stimmen würde er im Krieg in der Ukraine
ein wirklichen Unterschied machen und
ein paar Details und Fakten über den
Leopard zeigt uns jetzt Fahrer Schlink
der Leopard 2 gilt als einer der
modernsten und schlagkräftigsten
Kampfpanzer der Welt und er ist ein
deutscher Exportschlager 14 europäische
Länder sind im Besitz von insgesamt gut
2000 Panzern nicht alle von ihnen sind
einsatzbereit und nicht alle Länder sind
bereits sich bei der Anzahl in die
Karten schauen zu lassen Deutschland
soll rund 320 Leopard 2 besitzen am
meisten hat wohl Spanien mit fast 350
Finnland hat etwa 200 Modelle Polen das
am stärksten auf die Lieferung an die
Ukraine drängt besitzt nach eigenen
Angaben 247 Stück der ukrainische
Generalstab fordert für eine
erfolgreiche Gegenoffensive 300
Kampfpanzer mit mindestens 100 wäre es
laut Experten aber schon möglich die
Front punktuell zu durchbrechen doch es
kommt nicht allein auf die Zahl
einsatzbereiter Panzer an ukrainische
Soldaten müssen auf den Panzer geschult
werden zudem muss eine Logistikkette zur
Versorgung mit Ersatzteilen und
Treibstoff aufgebaut werden der Leopard
2 und seine Schlagkraft sie ist also
nicht nur eine Frage der Bauart
ihr habt viele Fragen gestellt ich habe
sie auch gesehen bei uns im Stream und
die kann uns jetzt beantworten
Militärexperte Gustav gressel jetzt bei
uns erneut schönen guten Abend guten
Abend eine Frage die ich total häufig
jetzt bei uns im Stream gelesen habe
gegen ein bisschen sehr ins Detail also
aber zurecht also es geht um die Anzahl
der Leopard Panzer steigen wir
vielleicht direkt damit ein und zwar
schreibt hier jetzt da bei Youtube
meinen sie es würde was bringen über 140
Leo Panzer zu schicken in ein Land das
600.000 Quadratkilometer groß ist ich
glaube eher nicht trotzdem symbolisch
das Überschreiten der roten Linie wie
schätzen Sie das ein wie viele Panzer
Leopard Panzer würden im Zweifel
überhaupt genug sein wenn man das so
sagen kann also signifikanten
Unterschied eine Brigade zusammenbringt
das in etwa 80 bis 90 Kampfpanzer
das Land ist groß die Front ist 1300 km
weiter aber es gibt ja noch immer
Schwerpunkte und dort würde es so eine
private eingesetzt werden
das zweite ist
wir gehen hier von einem relativ langen
Krieg aus ich war immer davor wenn
Glauke dass sozusagen der Krieg in den
nächsten Monaten dann beendet ist und
dann gehen wir alle heim und in diesem
langen Krieg kommt es ja auch auf die
die logistische Möglichkeit an die diese
Fähigkeit zu erhalten
und ich da darf daran erinnern dass zum
Beispiel Heimat also dieses Artillerie
Raketensystem das jetzt so für vorher
gesucht hat sondern eigentlich mit einer
Handvoll werfen anziehen und das ist
heute auch in etwa 30 Werfer sind die
hier doch entscheidendes leisten die
haben natürlich größere Reichweite aber
die werden auch immer nur
schwerpunktmäßig eingesetzt dort wo eben
heftige Kämpfe sind dort sozusagen
lohnen eine Ziele sich für ihren Einsatz
bieten und in so einem Fall werden
natürlich auch die Leopard bzw auch
abbrems je nachdem in welcher
Größenordnung sie dann kommen auch
solche schwerpunktgeräte
ja und jetzt habe ich hier gerade noch
weiter in den Kommentaren gelesen weil
es sind wirklich viele zusammengekommen
und zwar genau es geht ja auch darum es
sind ja in der Debatte jetzt im
scheinbar nicht nur die Leopard
Kampfpanzer sondern wie wir in Medien
berichten jetzt gehört haben geht es
also auch um den Kampfpanzer Abrams von
den USA dazu passt die Frage hier von
ECE bei Youtube er oder sie schreibt mit
wie vielen westlichen modernen
Kampfpanzern werden wir in der Ukraine
für dieses Jahr rechnen und werden sie
für eine rückeroberungsoffensive
ausreichen
ich schätze für eine eine Gegenoffensive
wird erst im Herbst ausreichen wenn wir
in wirklich über die Zahl kommen die die
vorhin gelernt wird und dann kommt es
auf darauf an wie viel andere
Waffensysteme Schützenpanzer auch ganz
okay hier Geräte Minenräumen Panzer und
so weiter sind dann auch verfügbar zu
diesem Zeitpunkt davor werden diese
ganzen Geräte sicher behilflich sein bei
der Abwehr der russischen früher als
Offensive und wenn auch dementsprechende
Abnutzung erfahren also man braucht
jetzt nicht glauben dass die das alle
Leopard Panzer da die Gefechte diese
jetzt geschickt werden auch überleben
also
mal schauen bei den Abrams die werden
jetzt gerade am Polen geliefert und die
seit Herbst die logistische
Infrastruktur auch dort aufgebaut ist
Grundvoraussetzungen dafür dass dieser
Panzer überhaupt in Ukraine geliefert
werden kann ich schätze dass also obwohl
sie natürlich jetzt angekündigt wird das
geliefert wird dass die praktische
implementation diese Lieferung eher
etwas später anläuft weil eben wie
gesagt in Polen ist man gerade Aufbau
der Infrastruktur begriffen und in
größeren Stückzahlen würde ich den
Abrams eher in der zweiten Jahreshälfte
vermuten aber wahrscheinlich aus
politischen Gründen eine kleine
Vorausabteilung
ihr rasch
und was könnte das jetzt für unmittelbar
in den nächsten Wochen bedeuten also
kämen die überhaupt rechtzeitig wie
lange dauert so was kämmen die
vielleicht sogar zu spät was hat
Russland entgegenzusetzen also da
schließt sich ja natürlich dann noch mal
ein ganzer Rattenschwanz Anfragen an
also russland hat entgegenzusetzen
giftige Kommentare von Herrn viele
Propaganda Sendungen wir haben ja in
Russland die Eskalationsstufe mobil
machen und Annexion ja schon im
September durchgeschnitten und in der
empelimitation dieser Eskalationsstufe
sind wir jetzt sind etwa 200.000 Mann
der russischen Arme noch in Russland
diese fließen jetzt langsam
wieder aufleben der russischen
offensivtätigkeit und das wird sich mit
weiteren einfließen dieser russischen
Kräfte intensivieren okay den Leopard
weiter liefern oder nicht ist völlig
egal also für die russische Seite die
haben ihre Offensive ja schon länger
seit Monaten geplant und exekutieren
jetzt wie sich die Ukraine dagegen
wehren können das hängt unter anderem
auch davon ab was für Rüstungsgüter
jetzt auch aus dem Westen kommen
natürlich nicht nur die Fahrzeuge
sondern auch die Munition Betriebsmittel
etc und hier ist in Ramstein schon
einiges
zustande gekommen ja nicht nur Kampfbahn
sondern eben auch Schützenpanzer viele
Mannschaftstransport Panzer
artilleriesysteme Munition Flieger
abwehrgerät das kann sich schon sehen
lassen und
bei den beiden Bodenfahrzeugen wird es
aufgrund der Ausbildungstätigkeit etc
noch ein bisschen teuer dauern bei den
bei Munition für die Abwehrfähigkeit
Artillerie gehen ja viele Systeme
schnell und ich hoffe dass die eben dann
auch bei der Verteidigung jetzt davon im
Don was ihre Wirkung tun werden
wenn wir darüber sprechen was die
Ukraine Russland entgegenzusetzen hat
dann lohnt es sich natürlich auch mal
die Panzer direkt zu vergleichen wir
haben dazu einen Bericht vorbereitet was
also der Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 den
russischen Panzern im Vorteil hat und
schauen da jetzt mal gemeinsam rein
einen Beitrag von Josua schwarz
der Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 ist stark
gepanzert er wiegt 60 Tonnen und hat
1500 PS er hat eine leistungsfähige 120
mm Glattrohrkanone ihre Aufgabe andere
Panzer und Fahrzeuge beschießen oder
zerstören oder der Infanterie durch
Beschuss von Häusern oder Stellungen
helfen
mit 70 Kilometern pro Stunde ist der
Leopard 2 besonders schnell und
beweglich die neueste Version des
Kampfpanzers kann Ziele in bis zu 5000
Metern Entfernung treffen
diese Werte erreichen die russischen
Kampfpanzer bei weitem nicht die
eingesetzten T-Modelle können nur in
einem Umkreis von 1.500 Metern Ziele
Treffen der modernste eingesetzte Panzer
T90 ist laut Militärexperten dem Leopard
2 in der Kombination aus Geschwindigkeit
und Zielgenauigkeit deutlich unterlegen
wir haben es jetzt gerade noch mal im
Beitrag gehört also wenn es dazu käme
hätte man damit dann wirklich also
wesentlich bessere Chancen gegenüber
Russland
es kommt immer sehr darauf an welche
Versionen von welcher Version wieder
reden aber jetzt ist der Leopard 26
angekündigt der ist in der Tat sehr gut
gepanzert und ein sehr leistungsfähiges
Gerät die meist verbreitete Variante für
Leopard und die meisten jetzt in der
Quantität für Lieferung in Frage
kommenden Kampfpanzer sind allerdings
die zu A4 Variante die etwas leichter
ist das macht das Bergen dieser Geräte
und die pionierunterstützung also
Brücken legen einfach auf der anderen
Seite ist natürlich nicht so stark
getanzt und hat nicht die langjährige
Kanone sondern die 1144 seine etwas
kürzere Kanone Kanone aber die ein einer
der Hauptvorteile in den ganzen
Diskussionen immer unterschlagen wird
ist der Vorteil der Munition beschaffen
die Munition für die Leopard 2 wird im
Westen hergestellt in Europa in den USA
in Südkorea hier können wir die danach
schon anmunition viel genauer
kontrollieren und auch planen wir können
Ukraine genau sagen was sie bekommen
können was nicht für die sowjetischen
Kampfpanzer muss also da haben wir ein
bisschen Produktion in osteuropäischen
Staaten die auch für den Kriegsbedarf
der Ukraine bei weitem nicht ausreicht
und wir müssen in Marokko in Pakistani
mit Namen Indonesien vor allen Dingen in
die USA sammeln dort Munition ein und
das wird mit jedem Monat des Krieges
schwieriger weil natürlich deren
Bestände auch nicht enden wollen sind
und man dann immer verhandeln muss um um
das Abtreten von Munition weil wir auch
mit Russland Welt bieten Russland kauft
ja auch Munition dort ein wo es sie
finden kann und all das führt bei der
Ukraine immer so ein bisschen so ein
unwohl wir finden wenn man eigentlich
nicht planen kann wie weit man mit der
Munition immer noch hat durchkommt und
dieses zweite Standbein einfach dass man
genauso wie das bei der Flieger ab ja
auch ist wo man natürlich erst 300 und
Bug hat aber auf der anderen Seite
ihres Tee nahrsam sondern andere
westliches Tier oder Artillerie
natürlich auch noch Munition für die
sowjetischen Kaliber geliefert wird aber
daneben auch nazisysteme verwendet wird
das macht den ganzen Einsatzführung ein
bisschen die Logistik flexibler weil man
eben nicht von solchen solchen
nadelöhren logistischerseits abhängig
ist und das macht für die Ukraine meiner
Ansicht nach weit größeren Unterschied
als jetzt die Debatte ob die
Zieloptiken oder die Kanone von dem
einen oder anderen Panzer besser ist
oder nicht dazu passt die Frage von
Molke Quark Quark bei youtube ist das
nicht strategisch längst überfällig die
Produktionskapazitäten der
Rüstungsindustrie vor allem Munition
jetzt hoch zu fahren
absolut das kann ich nur mit Rufzeichen
versehen und doppelt unterstreichen die
Amerikaner haben hier in
Sommer schon angefangen das Budget dafür
auszustocken nachdem das mit den Firmen
immer ein bisschen dauert wenn die die
Effektivität diese Maßnahmen erst dieses
Jahr wirklich zu spüren bekommen ähm
haben vieles was in Europa diskutiert
wird bleibt Absichtserklärung hier sind
wir weit hinter den gesteckten Zielen
einher beim Leopard 2 wenn man die
Panzer Produktion Vergleich der neue
Leopard 2 hat drei Jahre Wartezeit und
dann produziert kein weh zwei Panzer pro
Monat die russischen
panzerwerke
etwa 200 bis 250 Kampfpanzer werden dort
jetzt unter kriegswirtschaftsbedingungen
pro Jahr produziert das heißt
deutlich also 16 Panzer mindestens pro
Monat
da sind wir hinterher und vor allen
Dingen für die für den Ersatz der der
jetzt an die Ukraine gelieferten
Fahrzeuge es betreiben wir die
europäischen Streitkräfte den Leopard ja
auch nicht zum Spaß und weil das so
hübsch ausschaut sondern der hat ja auch
innerhalb der NATO konkrete Rollen und
Aufgaben muss jetzt auch Ersatz
beschafft werden und da ist es natürlich
auch so dass desto größer die
Bestellungen ist desto mehr starten
gleichzeitig hier auftreten und kaufen
desto günstiger wird der Preis und desto
schneller ist die Lieferung sie können
das etwas vergleichen mit dem
Unterschied zwischen einem vom Tischler
herstellten handmöbel dass ein
Einzelstück ist ist
spezifisch für einen Kunden und
Stangenware von Ikea desto mehr Kunden
desto höher der turnout desto billiger
der Preis und desto schneller die
Lieferung
kommen wir noch mal ganz konkret zu dem
womit wir jetzt auch die Sendung
begonnen haben also das waren ja
Medienberichte dass eventuell eben
Deutschland doch den Part 2 liefern
könnte und die USA eben den Abrams es
gibt nämlich auch noch einige Fragen zu
dieser möglichen us-entscheidung über
die wir glaube ich auch noch mal
sprechen müssen und zwar lese ich hier
von
Lars Heidemann der schrieb bei Youtube
wenn jetzt alle liefern Polen hat Abrams
bestellt wer einen Ringtausch
amerikanischer Abrams für polnische Leos
nicht sinniger als
Abrams direkt an Ukraine zu schicken da
finden wird um die Logistik simpel zu
halten
rein militärisch ja aber es ist eben
eine politische Entscheidung anscheinend
das eben Deutschland diese Leopard 2
Entscheidung nicht treffen will ohne
dass amerikanische Abrams in die Ukraine
gehen
es wurde ja vorher schon Beitrag
angesprochen der Abrams verbraucht mehr
Kraftstoff er ist auch zumindest wenn
man die neuesten Varianten gegen die 2 4
2 5 Variante vergleicht deutlich
schwieriger das heißt für für Brücken
für anderes pioniergerät für Berge Gerät
das eben auf in Ukraine vorhanden ist
meistens so auf 50 Tonnen ausgelegt ist
da kann man einen 55 Tonnen schweren
zwei vier auch noch aus dem Akazien aber
mit einem 72 Tonnen schweren ehms wird
wird's dann schon ähm knifflig äh wäre
es auch noch für sich einfach aber wenn
man sich auf den Leopard 2 einigt und
da Polen den Abrams ohnehin schon
einführt fließt der wie gesagt es ist
aber jetzt ein politischer Kuhhandel und
wenn es so ist dann soll es sein
wir haben immer mal wieder also auch
dieses Thema angesprochen in unseren
Streams und heute kommt die Frage auch
erneut auf und zwar von Screen HD der
bei Youtube er oder sie sich fragt warum
werden nicht im großen Stile Leopard 1
Panzer geliefert die gibt es ja auch
noch
die gibt's auch noch das ist auch eine
gute Frage denn wir haben auch in diesem
Krieg gesehen dass diese viel
besprochene Rolle des Kampfpanzers
nämlich der Kampf gegen andere
Kampfpanzer eigentlich im Aufgaben
Profil von Kampfpanzern nur einen
kleinen Teil dessen darstellt also der
direkte Kampf ukrainische Kampfpanzer
gegen russischer Kampfpanzer meistens
leisten Kampfpanzer Feuer Unterstützung
für Infanterie im Häuser Kampf im im
Kampf wo in Vertrieb größere
Geländestücke überwinden muss etc dafür
tut der Leopard eins genau so wie jeder
andere Panzer er tut bei der Lieferung
unseren Streitkräften ja weniger weh
weil er nirgendwoaktiven Dienst ist
deshalb kann man ihn auch so liefern
plus die Ukraine hat das Problem dass
sie immer noch eine sehr unsichere
Nordgrenze hat mit Belarus als
Wackelkandidaten mit einer sehr langen
Grenze zu Russland wo man zwar die
russischen Streitkräfte hinausgedrängt
hat wo man aber eigentlich nicht weiß
was da noch über diese Grenze kommt und
hier werden Reserven bereitgehalten
bei solchen Reserven hätte ein Leopard 1
eher die Funktion eines Jagdpanzers also
ausgebauten Stellungen andere
Kampfpanzer beschießen und bekämpfen zum
Teil im Panzer schwierigen Gelände wo
man sie einfach sperren und kanalisieren
kann das kann der Leopard 1 sehr gut
dafür wäre geeignet da würde er anderer
kann andere Kampfpanzer frei machen
jetzt dort gebunden werden das wäre
eigentlich eine sehr große Hilfe
das Problem beim Leopard 1 er wurde halt
sehr lange nicht bewegt das heißt die
die Vorlaufzeiten in der Industrie
diesen herzurichten bereitzustellen die
sind sehr lange und leider Gottes
haben wir diesen Export Auftrag den die
Ukraine wollte die ja seit März letzten
Jahres kaufen
bis jetzt liegen gelassen und nicht
bearbeitet dementsprechend hat auch die
Industrie nicht gewusst ob sie überhaupt
mal reparieren wird können ob das Sinn
macht oder nicht und dieser Zeit laufen
jetzt natürlich leider hinterher
ich lese auch einige sorgenvolle
Kommentare und Fragen bei uns im Stream
ich möchte mal ein paar Vorlesen zum
einen habe ich gesehen ich finde Scholz
macht das richtig das Thema absolut
nicht zu überstürzen jemand anderes
schreibt peinlich Scholz ist so unfähig
Nein zu sagen es ist peinlich und ein
dritter eine dritte schreibt das
eskaliert der Amerikaner ist ja weit weg
da schließt sich die Frage an von
complesserl
nee entschuldigung ich bin hier
verrutscht in der Zeile
so jetzt habe ich gleich genau doch es
war komplett besser habe ich doch
richtig gesehen die Frage lautet da die
Panzer in Deutschland produziert werden
was ist der logistische Folge Schritt
Putins nee so entschuldigung ich mache
das ganze noch mal ich wollte eine
andere Frage stellen und bin hier vor
lauter Fragen konfus und zwar ist die
Frage die ähm zu den Kommentaren passte
warum lässt sich Deutschland derart in
den Krieg hineinziehen obwohl immer
behauptet wurde die NATO dürfen keine
Kriegspartei werden sind Waffenlieferung
wirklich alternativlos
sind alternativlos wenn man nicht will
dass die Ukraine den Krieg verliert doch
Waffenlieferungen wird noch nicht kriegt
der Kriegspartei Deutschland ist Teil
der NATO und als solches durch den
Artikel 5 gedeckt das heißt ein Angriff
Russland auf Deutschland
würde automatisch den Bündnisfall
ausrufen und es werden vor allen Dingen
in die USA natürlich dann verpflichtet
Deutschland zu helfen würden das auch
tun das haben sie auch und deshalb
Präsident beiden in verschiedensten
reden sehr klar herausgestrichen und
bedeutet und die Amerikaner haben
zurzeit etwa 100.000 Mann Truppen vor
allen Dingen viele und sehr moderne
Kampfflugzeuge in Europa stationiert um
diesen Worten auch wirklich sozusagen
real darstellbare Fähigkeiten zu lassen
von diesem Hintergrund ist die
Panikmache die also
vor allen Dingen von der AFD und der
Linkspartei hier geführt wurde dass wir
jetzt Kriegspartei werden und dass der
kriegt rot natürlich
heiß los also man sieht das auch an den
russischen eine Art wie russische Chemie
den Kampf führt und wo sie ihre Kräfte
zusammenzieht der kalining gerade auch
Last wäre im Falle eines Krieges mit der
Natur verwundbar man hat dort Kräfte
abgezogen
dass das elfte das elf der ami-chor das
dort stationiert ist ist nur meine
rumpfeinheit und nicht ein
einsatztauglich die sechste Armee die
eben gegenüber den baltischen Staaten in
unserem petersburg stationiert ist die
ist in Cardiff schon verblutet die
deristische militärgeheimnis Nummer 25%
der Truppenstärke der friedensmäßigen
Truppenstärke der Russischen Föderation
an der Grenze der baltischen Staaten
stehen die Russische Föderation
verschießt ihre s300-systeme als Boden
Boden Rakete weil ihr die Macht vom
Körper ausgehen um die Ukraine
anzugreifen die S300 ist die Rückgrat
der russischen Flieger Abwehr nicht nur
das Heeres sondern auch zum Schutz also
auch der der Fliegerkräfte zum Schutz
der kritischen Infrastruktur und
und der luftaufenbasen Ufer einigen auch
der Marine russische russische Marine
Streitkräfte und Flottenverbände werden
mit S300 geschützt wenn man die Munition
dafür breitwilligsten seit Monaten schon
in Ukraine verballert dann kann man sich
nicht darauf vorbereiten gegen die NATO
Krieg zu führen denn ohne diese S300
ohne die Munition Bevorratung überlässt
man sozusagen NATO Kampfflugzeugen in so
einem Fall den Himmel all das deutet
darauf hin dass all diese Drohungen die
mit WDF ausspricht all das was da über
den Bildschirm läuft im russischen
Fernsehen das ist ein schüchterung das
ist Propaganda es gibt zur Zeit solange
die russische Armee in der Ukraine
kämpft die Kapazitäten nicht ein zweiten
großkrieg anzufangen schon gar nicht
schon gar nicht gegen die NATO einen
Krieg gegen die NATO könnte Russen
führen wenn das erfolgreichen Ukraine
wäre wenn sie sie unterwirft wenn es
dort eine eine vorwärtsbasis einrichtet
und dann natürlich die große Hoffnung
positiv auf langfrist wenn Kinder
irgendwann Polizei waren eine
Pazifikkrieg startet und die Amerikaner
in Europa eben nicht eingreifen können
dann wird die Sache brenzlig aber um
sowas zu verhindern wäre es eben genau
wichtig dass Russland nicht die Ukraine
erobert und hier nicht erfolgreich ist
und seine Armee auch dann in den Jahren
danach noch reparieren und wieder
aufbauen muss und eben keine Abenteuer
eingehen kann und das zu erreichen gehen
Leopard in die Ukraine aber jetzt doch
noch ganz kurz die User Frage von
komplexer dazu also da die Panzer in
Deutschland produziert werden was ist
der logische Folgeschritt Putins
putin wird seine Frühjahrsoffensive so
durchführen wie er sie geplant hat bzw
in generalstaatschef und die die
einsatzführenden Kommanden ihre
Frühjahrsoffensive planen ist wie gesagt
es gibt außer Propaganda jetzt keinen zu
erwartenden großen Schritt der
der Russischen Föderation das da die
Eskalation wurde durch Moskau schon
gesetzt man hat schon mobil gemacht man
hat
schon zu Annexion gegriffen und wir
leben schon in dieser Phase der erhöhten
Eskalation wir sind und die Eskalation
wie gesagt die wurde doch Moskau gesetzt
ist müssen wir damit leben und schauen
wie das wieder einfangen
dann zum Schluss jetzt aber noch die
Frage also wenn wir in die Zukunft
schauen denn jetzt für die kommenden
Wochen was erwarten sie da denn also
stand jetzt gibt es ja eben noch keine
kampfpanzerlieferungen und wenn ja dann
scheint das ja auch noch zu dauern also
ist die Ukraine jetzt einfach auch noch
zu schlecht gerüstet für eigene Vorstöße
erwarten Sie nur russische Vorstöße wenn
sie in die nächsten Wochen in die
Zukunft blicken wie sieht das da aus im
Kriegsverlauf
also operativ bedeutende Vorstöße der
Ukraine erwarte ich nicht ganz einfach
weil die Kräfte jetzt diese Umbach
mutigen irgendwas brauchen zu hoch sind
das sind so viele Kräfte gebunden um
etwas etwas Großes anzureißen es gibt
kleinere offensiven es gibt kleinere
Vorstöße der Ukraine noch im Norden im
du kannst
da kann man in den nächsten Wochen auch
bisschen Fortschritte erreichen aber das
ist ein taktische
taktische Angriffe da geht es um das
Erreichen bessere Linien um das
Erreichen von wichtigen Orten und so
weiter und mal Voraussetzungen für für
weiteres Vorgehen zu schaffen aber jetzt
noch keinen großen Durchstoß ich glaube
auch nicht dass die Ukraine eine große
Offensive anfangen solange sie weiß dass
sie in diese 200.000 Mann mobil gemacht
der Kräfte noch in Russland sind und
jederzeit eingesetzt können weil wo auch
immer man ist eine große Offensive
startet dann können eben genau diese
Reserven zum Einsatz kommen und den
Ukraine dann auch in die Flanke fallen
ich hier ist es auch persönlicher Sicht
um die eigenen Kräfte zu bewahren in den
nächsten Wochen wahrscheinlich auch in
den nächsten Monaten immer besser in der
Defensive zu bleiben und einmal
abzuweitern was kommt die die Chance auf
eine Gegenoffensive ergibt sich dann
meistens aus den linken gebliebenen
offensiven wenn er eben Verbände
verbluten wenn sich Frontabschnitte
ausgedünnt werden um neue Reserven zu
bauen etc aus diesen Möglichkeiten
ergeben sich dann die die Chancen
durchzustoßen wieder wieder Gelände gut
zu machen
sagt Militärexperte Gustav gressel danke
für Ihre Einschätzung heute abend vielen
herzlichen Dank
und danke auch für eure Aufmerksamkeit
eure vielen Fragen ich hoffe ich konnte
so viele wie möglich einbringen und auch
beantworten lassen wir schauen also alle
gespannt auf morgen kommt da wo möglich
eine Entscheidung in Sachen Kampfpanzer
in Deutschland oder in den USA wir sind
auf jeden Fall für euch live dann also
gerne bis morgen tschüss